i appreciate you
talking to me about season two i have
been very anxiously awaiting new
episodes i am so happy the show is back
awesome yeah i was gonna say i'm sure
you
you are as well so what what are you
most excited about with season two
and story you're telling especially
knowing how long fans of the show have
been waiting to see more of the show
oh well we can't begin to really satisfy
the and and to make up for the
long overdue weight you know the fans
had to endure
um for so many various reasons it's
it's all we can do is feed them at this
point it's like a restaurant you were
standing outside
the weight was long you were hungry your
stomach got to the point where
your hunger had subsided and you're sort
of just there and you were hoping to eat
but at some point you're like
am i gonna just go home with no food
what am i gonna do well
we found a table for you now you get to
sit down and consume the food
and it won't be disappointing and
hopefully you'll love it we really are
we have a great season i think it does
go
sort of subtly ascends into
the the you know gets better and better
i think one two three
we just keep going and very i think the
shifts of season two are a lot more
subtle
and a lot more um gradual throughout the
season than it was for season one
because i think season one
it was it was literally like you know
episode one really set us up before i
found ourselves
our groove eight was sort of like whoa
this is a really crazy show
baby in the cornfield what is going on
and you know we get to 10
and it's like oh this hospital it stands
alone episode feels like
that i don't you know you don't even
know what you're watching and then and
then 13 you're like we have such a huge
cliffhanger
i really feel like third uh episode two
is sort of
sorry season two really in terms of
gradual ascending
of of plot line really gets gets
stronger and stronger
and by by the end of the season again
we'll have a
very good cliffhanger i feel like that
really puts people in a situation where
they have to come back for
season three and they have to come back
and check us out and see if we got
the store for him which is what you want
you know you want that you know
yeah i mean the first question that i
had with this show
immediately was does it pick right up
where it left off because
with the first season finale leaving
everyone wondering whether
kristin is possessed herself was that
sort of the question you had or did the
kings give you any definitive answers
about it when you did the finale episode
did you know where that would be going
uh
no i wasn't 100 sure where that was
going to be going
i think they told us at some point
before we started filming or
at some point you know again time seems
to have
you know escaped me in terms of what
when something happened
when did it not happen uh during the
season prior to the season at some point
we sort of knew the trajectory of what
the character was going to be doing
from any given moment in terms of like
possession or not possessed and things
of that nature
but there was a question mark and i
think it's good to have a question mark
throughout the season for
all of the all the audience members all
the people who are watching the fans i
think they really
want to continuously try to figure out
what's going on with her and that's a
great place for her character to be
that's a great place for them to be
as a viewer you know um but we had the
same questions i wasn't sure we're like
oh boy you know because we're like
are we going to exercise exercise
kristen do i have to put my hands on her
too is somebody going to put their hands
on her you know
do you personally enjoy when things are
left a bit
more ambiguous in the storytelling or
are you someone who prefers getting
direct and definitive answers to things
no
ambiguity is where we live i think we
have to sort of live there because
we have we have such a strong argument
and such strong tangible evidence for
either side
in terms of what they believe how can we
sort of
answer that definitively for anyone
because we're representing all sides in
somewhat equal fashion so how do we
then turn around and definitively define
what is or is not
i think a lot of times we we leave it
sort of open-ended and
even though it may seem like there's an
answer there's always a certain amount
of
unanswered questions if you pay
attention to the entire episode you go
okay
all right well that appears to be this
but if you really
think about like the pieces of the
puzzle that were not answered you go
well what about that
they never talked about that you know
people still ask some questions from
person
like okay that that's fine but what
about this
and to that end we have no answers or
answers that we're willing to give
you know when you do a show like this
does it make you look at
and evaluate your own beliefs
differently or does it really just sort
of reinforce
what your own beliefs are uh i think
they always
i think it always question calls into
question your own beliefs to some degree
you always have to figure out
uh what what about
this thing makes me
question my own stance
and anytime you come into that
you know anytime you come into that
contact with that
it's it's like most people brace and
they sort of shut down and they go well
you know
you know the cognitive dissonance or
whatever and they sort of like go into
this mode of like a trigger they can't
can't deal with it because that's not
their reality and they don't want to
interpret or and
take in what they're in the new
information that they're they're getting
new information it scares people because
that requires us to change we don't want
to change we don't want to sort of
wow you mean to tell me i've been
walking around thinking the wrong thing
for
however long and for some people that's
refreshing they want that so then they
can go okay well
at least i can change and i can move on
and now that i have the
the actual answers or the actual real
information
now i can live my life based off of that
new information that i received as
opposed to consistently doing the same
thing
i think that's a scary thing about
people i think they don't want to know
they don't want to know like
i i i was you know really happy when i
found there's some things
what they call life hacks you know
sometimes you find these things that
actually like
wait a minute that's that's i could just
do it that way and that was
why not that's what that's what you know
if you look at life hacks
because it's so simple and so small and
minut you know like the pillow thing
where you can put the pillow on in five
seconds if you just do it the right way
put the corners in
that's a life hack right you know
there's a way to grow to peel a boiled
egg that could take you you know
20 seconds left that's a little life
hack these are things that you can
implement you know that will boom look
at how much time you save right
but if you compare that to deeper
notions deeper or deeper ideas hey it's
just as tangible
to have a better sense of understanding
than to walk around with blinders on and
to do the same thing over and over
your character is the one on his team
that's sort of on a belief island by
himself while everyone else is a bit
more skeptical than he is
and because of that i really sort of
love the dynamic that we get between
him and this nun was it nice for him to
have someone that he can sort of talk to
and share ideas with who
is a believer like him oh yeah yeah yeah
i think that character was definitely
introduced
for that for that purpose you know to
sort of allow david to have a
conversation with someone who actually
understands and believes so we're not
always in conflict with about ideas
and and so we can get a little a little
more
deeper into what those
those people those people what people
like david
are and what they feel so now
we can understand them a little better
and connect with those
those ideas a little better because the
debate is great
but at some point we have to have enough
conversation um
in both places and and depth of some
depth that we can sort of connect with
the characters and understand
how they see the world and i think you
know sister andrea was introduced for
that purpose it was really important
leland is such an interesting character
because he's always manipulating
everyone about everything and we still
really have no clue what his true
motivation actually
is yep what was your reaction to finding
out that
he sort of essentially be the case of
the week for this team that they would
sort of have to
take him on in that way oh well i mean
we just i mean leland's so annoying you
just go oh god i
he's like i don't david hates him he
doesn't
really want to be in the same room with
him he's just it's it's
just a burden he's just it's just so
much about him that
just everyone hates him you know
and so to that end it's like to finally
we have to deal with him
it's just you can't even imagine what it
feels like and so
we'll have to endure this for quite a
bit of time so we can figure out
what to do with this person but the
thing is that there's also a part of the
script or part of the story that you try
to figure out well
maybe maybe maybe leland is actually
needs help maybe
leland actually is a person that needs
help and maybe this is
something that they can help him with
but first you have to believe him
you know could you ever imagine you'd be
playing a character who has nightmares
of michael emerson dancing around in the
fields
oh my god no i never never saw that
coming
never i love that visual it just was so
great
especially with such a creepy character
i know
i know go ahead no i was just gonna say
what do you enjoy about what he brings
to the show because it seems like
with something so unpredictable about
that character that it must be really
fun to do
scenes with him you know it it's his
he's sort of the
he is the it's a comic relief of this
show
in places where it seems inappropriate
to have comic relief
but into that and we are able to give
the audience a little bit of a
breather in terms of always feeling like
on edge or like something's gonna happen
or like what's gonna happen next and
like you know that that allows people to
breathe a bit and i think when you're
watching a show like that
when you can find places to relax and
take the foot off the gas in terms of
edginess and feeling like there's an
anxiety that there might be something
lurking around the corner
that gives people a chance to relax and
to get comfortable and to then
get scared again or to then you know
feel like okay here we are again
but you gotta have those those shifts of
um
of tone and i think he allows us to do
that
you will always be identified and
remembered as
luke cage your performance in that show
was so great i thought you brought
so much to that character and you got to
do that
cameo appearance in the jessica jones
series finale
what was it like to get to go back and
and do that since you didn't really sort
of get the chance to wrap
up lou cage's story on his own show did
having that
give you any sort of sense of closure to
get to
you know play that character again
to be honest no it didn't bring i didn't
give a chance to have any closure it was
it was sort of you know
there were so many places we could have
taken it uh you know there's obviously
the alias series where jessica
you know luke had a child and they sort
of like you know sort of have this
you know adult life they're trying to
live and there's this moment where it's
like okay well
now they are working out their blue
collars sort of
making ends meet life together which is
very interesting you know way
there's obviously the journey that luke
had on his own series where
you know harlem you know um
harlem parrot holmes paradise where you
know he's taking over the club and
well is he gonna be uh a bad guy or a
guy that you know
it's on the other side of the law and
who's going to stop him
that was another interesting you know
thing to watch him be maybe a little
gangster and that would have been cool
too so
i don't think there's any closure to it
nor do i feel like we were able to get
any of that closure
by having the appearance in jessica
jones but you know it is what it is i
mean
it's one of those things where we we'll
just never know you know i think there's
a lot of shows that live in that space
where it's like oh man
you know what you know it's unfortunate
but that's just this is one of the
things that happened in television
sometimes
yeah i mean obviously you have to say
goodbye to every character you play at
some point but is it
bittersweet to say goodbye to a
character when it does feel like there
was still so much more of this image
yeah yeah of course i think so i but i
mean the only good the good thing about
it i guess the positive thing about it
is that you know with
something like that you'll always have a
fond memory of something that didn't
stay too long you know that you like
that you know that's you know it's like
a relationship or anything else that
never reached its peak or you know or
dissent you don't have any negative
memories of it because it will live in
this place of
perfection or some sense of promise at
all times in your life and you don't
have to
you so you're always thinking like it's
a fun you know romanticized notion
that what could have been what is your
collaborative relationship like with
the kings you have a history with them
so what's it like
as far as working with them how actively
do you get the opportunity to make
suggestions
with them i just try to stay out of
their way they're really good at what
they do
i i i i email or text sometimes just to
figure out
you know is this what it means does this
mean what i think it means
uh it are we going this direction
um maybe a line thing i i try to stay
out of the way i really you know
very few times i really feel like i mean
i want to have a conversation
and i think you know with the great
relationship great thing about it i
think robert we talked about at one
point and
you know they kind of let us do what we
do and they do what they do
and then it works you know it works in
that sort of autonomy
having that understanding that the
process you know which they work in
process in which we work and
you know it's a great working
relationship and so you know i can't you
know couldn't ask for more it's really
just been great
have you already had conversations about
what season three could look like and
what
you might continue to explore or be more
general bigger picture conversations is
it more specific
how did they approach that oh yeah
absolutely
we definitely had the conversation in
that and i think it's
so much promise of where it could be and
if you once we get to episode
the last episode of season two it's like
oh boy well it's that's a lot to
to consider so i kind of know in general
like hey
this is it's got a lot of potential of
what we could do with this and it's
going to be great but um and we
discussed it but now it's like well
let's just let's see we're going to get
a chance to show that
this show really is a combination of so
many things for
me it's really the psychological horror
aspect that stands out that's the thing
that kind of
haunts me when i think about the show
how do you view the show is there a
genre or an aspect
of it that most speaks to you
i think you hit it on you really uh hit
it the
psychological you know fear factor of
what you really are dealing with and who
and who
who's really the bad guy or the person
that you have to concern yourself or to
worry about
in the world and i think we talk about
all the time you know evil
alludes to a lot of different things um
and i want people to sort of
understand that evil comes in such small
increments such small dosage doses at
any given moment in our day and it's not
always consistent everybody who's evil
who has evil in them isn't always evil
you know there's a
there's a real um there's a real
uh misunderstanding i feel like from the
aspect of evil being
one way and good being the other thing
and i think there's such great
in gray matter in between it that
connects the two
that we are often trying to only stay
on one side or consider one side and to
that end we cannot do that that is not
really possible
and so people have to understand that we
all have the potential
to be good but we also have the
potential to be evil can we talk about
their you know their good deed of the
day their good deed this week or
whatever right
which kind of alludes to the fact that
they weren't doing good deeds all along
like
the good deed like they oh you did a
good deed it stood out
you know they stood they parked they
pulled over and they helped someone
change the tire
they pulled over they considered helping
someone do something out of the ordinary
because it was selfless
well that loses the fact that that's not
the norm for them otherwise it would
have been their good deed
so people say that all the time so that
means well what else are you doing rest
of the day are you walking through a
life with blinders on
being a selfless a selfish prick
are you are you evil most of the times
and is this your one moment of like
clarity of like you know what
i'm gonna be good i'm gonna do something
that's not about me and
i feel like that's where the show sort
of lives in this area of
reality not not what we want it to be
but what it is
yeah i mean i think aside from the the
great writing and the great acting from
the cast of the show
one of the reasons it made my list of
best television
is because it really does kind of sneak
up on you it's
it's never exactly what you expect it
always just kind of stays with you and
haunts you and makes you think about
things you didn't realize you'd be
thinking about
and i i love that yeah no i agree i
agree it does sneak up on you and
in every way from title to the
presentation to
what you think you're sitting on the
watch and what you are
looking forward to seeing the next
episode what can you say about
david's ark specifically this season
what have you enjoyed about what you've
gotten to explore with them in this
season i i think what i'm what i'm
really
looking forward to and enjoying about
uh or enjoying about the season and what
the fans can look forward to is
basically
watching david sort of slowly um
um come to he he's sort of unraveling by
the end in a sense
he's it's this idea and this this this
nagging feeling like what he's doing is
it like
is this right is it going to be because
i mean he's doing it for a purpose right
he's doing it so he can sort of
serve god he's doing it so he can sort
of like find
you know a safe haven for himself you
know this has been a place of refuge for
him
but once he's in it you know it's like
well i mean i don't know if you can get
out of it you know it's not like it's
kind of like
you know you i don't you can't just go
well not what i thought i think i'll
walk away now
it's kind of it's kind of hard to do
that and i think by the i think this
whole idea of like
will he won't he for a while it's going
to be very very
compelling and and by the end i think
we'll
be surprised at the outcome but um but
it'll just set us up for a wonderful
third season um that that's the journey
though of dealing with like
how his intimacy with god and being a
chosen um
conduit for for good and what he gets
out of his life
by being that connected to god and sort
of seeing the world
you know in in a way and i think sister
andrea's character talked about it
once you've seen the world and this is
like a
talk about you know being awakened
awakened being woke this
goes another level like if you can
actually see the stuff that's going on
behind the curtain in the world not i'm
not just talking politically
but literally seeing spirits and demons
and things of that nature
that people can't see once you've been
opened to that world
how do you turn around how do you go
back if you ever were
you know their ignorance is bliss well
if someone ever
let you see what's really going on
how do you go back to your normal life
and that's what david has to consider
yeah it's not just a you know i don't
like this job anymore i'm going to quit
it
yeah it's you know you do you quit god
like how does that work
yeah i mean if you're if you're a
homicide detective for 15 20 years
you're a homicide detective or something
like that i mean
however long you get a chance to do that
work i mean what like what is your life
outside of it i mean they don't have a
choice they burn out but there's a
certain
residual thing that have you have with
certain occupations i don't think david
has an
exit strategy for this he's pretty deep
in it now
well i appreciate you talking about it i
love talking about the show because i
feel like there's just endless
conversation because there's so many
questions and so many big picture
questions with it
yeah i appreciate you talking to me
about it and i can't wait to see the
rest of the season
oh thank you so much i appreciate it